All right, let's begin.
You can join the server, you can join,
okay, okay.
Hello, you already got it, yeah,
you just have to jump in, yeah.
So it was quite a long break, how is it
going, John?
I just completely cut off all my English
training line and did some other stuff,
just resting with my friends, doing some
work and, yeah, still working on my,
hold on a second, how can I name this
thing,
ah, foreign passport, all right,
all right, still working on my foreign
passport, yeah.
You know, I'm in Kazakhstan but I still
have a Russian citizen and I have to
refresh this one, kind of a pain in the
ass actually but a work in progress,
so,
all right, okay, thank you very much for
preparing the agenda and I also have tried
to prepare my, ah, my thoughts about our
favorite question, tell me about you,
and I decided to do it in a little bit of
different way, you know, I tried to answer
it in, completely in Russian just to
structure the pure thoughts so we can,
we can train it and practice separately in
English here and see how it works.
Of course I will, of course I will try to
answer it in English.
Just, nothing really interesting,
just the common tasks, everything is going
in a chill, quite chilly, so, yeah,
I, the most thing I have been focused
during this rest is my aim, you know,
my friend just jumped in deadlock game,
you know, from Valve, this is an action
shooter and during my life I was,
I sucked really hard in FPS, FPS like
games, and I'm trying to just fix it in
able to, in order to be able to just play
with them, and there is a rabbit hole,
there's so much, so much information,
so many different techniques how you can
hold a mouse, how you can smoothly get a
movement, how you can track the,
track the targets, and et cetera,
et cetera.
It was really fun and I'm still trying to
train my aim, and yeah, but now it's
better to focus back to English.
Besides, besides my, the fact that all of
my social contacts, primarily speaking in
Russian, and all of my social
communications in Russian, that means,
besides this fact, all the others
information that I'm consuming is in
English.
All my YouTube line, music, but music is
without words, so, yeah, don't worry,
even the articles, even...
Yes, that's correct.
The only practice I got before our class
is one hour of warm-up in that Discord
channel, just to be able to speak more,
a little bit more clearly at least,
so, yeah.
You mentioned that one of your last weeks
was chaotic, if I remember.
Was there some problems or some issues you
got?
Could you...
Was you able to resolve everything?
Well, now I got the full picture,
all right, kind of unfortunate,
actually.
Did his parents pay for the window?
I didn't have, unfortunately, I didn't
have the same situation, I don't even have
a car, but I can imagine they just paid
the raw amount from a check you provided,
not the rest of the resources.
Good final, actually.
No, honestly, I didn't even open an agenda
yet, yeah, so, I don't know anything that
you have prepared for this lesson,
but yeah, I got it, this is a good
approach, I think.
Moreover, I will try to...
No, no, no, before that, I'm just...
I just want to notice that I'm still
trying to answer some random generic
questions that come in in a technical
interview in my specialization,
and I just noticed that more frequently
I'm getting a technical gap than English,
than an actual English gap, and because of
that I will try to answer the questions in
Russian between our lessons, and so,
yeah, we can practice a bit of English.
This is the reason, yeah, why I prepared
the Russian answer.
I'm just also putting it, putting a note
for myself, just in case.
Yeah, so, yeah, we can read it right now.
Oh, alright.
Okay, let me read it out loud.
So, Decoding European Recruitment for HR
and Talent Acquisition Teams Truly
Evaluated.
Screening calls with Talent Acquisition TA
specialists and HR recruiters in Europe
are designed to filter out engineers who
are purely execution-focused rather than
strategy-aligned.
Recruiters frequently evaluate candidates
against three hidden criteria.
Quantified business impact,
cross-functional autonomy, and cultural
adaptability within distributed teams.
Oh, God, I almost forgot how it feels to
read the passage out loud.
Okay, a resume that merely lists technical
keywords like React, TypeScript,
Next.js, Redux, Tailwind will fail to
stand out against hundreds of competing
applications.
Hold on a second, I'm going to re-read
this once again.
I lost the meaning.
A resume that merely lists technical
keywords like React, TypeScript,
Next.js, Redux, Tailwind will fail to
stand out against hundreds of competing
applications.
Okay, to capture recruiter attention,
your CV and interview narrative must link
a front-end execution directly to
measurable business KPI.
Instead of saying responsible for building
React components, managing state and
writing unit tests, an aligned European CV
states architectured a server-side
rendering pipeline and modular design
system that reduced JavaScript bundle size
by 32%, improved LSP from 3.8 to 1.1,
and directly lifted checkout conversation
by 20%, saving €3,500 annually in
serverless CDN rendering overhead.
Oh, my God, this sentence is so AI-ed,
but okay, I got it.
All right,
all right, all right.
Furthermore, HI managers look for
candidates who exhibit strong technical
leadership, demonstrating how they mentor
junior engineers, drive design alignment
across cross-functional products,
squats, pairing with UX designers and
back-end leads, and navigate ambiguous
product specs without requiring
micromanagement.
Yeah, all right, all right, yeah,
I get the point.
Before,
strictly after this text, I can comment
that I recently watched a few videos from
a guy on YouTube.
He doesn't have much subscribers,
but it doesn't matter.
The main point he tried to deliver is that
it's really necessary to put some notes in
your CV about the value of the things you
did for the business, not the technical
depths, the value for the business.
That's the point.
That's what recruiters are trying to find
in your CV.
And yeah, I totally agree.
It's easy to put some random numbers,
but when it comes to prove it,
it's really easy to catch some people
kind of in the same way, just in a more
safe approach.
Let me put another note about these terms.
Just review the notes.
All right.
Yeah, we can pick any question.
I remember this method, star method.
Yeah, we can pick any and just try it out.
Yeah, thanks, John.
Hold on a moment.
I will just bring up my Russian option to
just catch my thoughts if I will lost.
All right, yeah, thanks, John.
Looking back for last few years,
I worked in two companies, and I raised
from a middle position to a senior.
On my previous one, I worked...
Oh, my God.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's OK.
OK, we have to practice this one.
Give me a second, please.
I'm just trying to...
I'm just trying to align the method.
All right, I will look at my Russian
option and we'll try to make some stuff.
OK, on my last position, I worked with a
team that worked around ERP system in oil
and gas industry.
The front end was...
There was only one front end team that
worked with different...
Some different...
Oh, my God.
Why it's so difficult?
Why it becomes so difficult in English?
I thought it will be much easier.
All right, all right.
That was unified.
All right.
Yeah, it will be better to provide a
screen demonstration.
Maybe, maybe.
So here is just a common translator,
and I write everything myself.
No LLM, zero LLM.
And I have tried to write it, you know,
as a transcription of an actual live
interview.
The way I would actually answer this
question on live.
And the translation is kind of sucks,
but it just provides some basic words and
the thoughts in general.
And what I'm trying to do, I'm trying to
read this one and get the main thoughts
and just translate it back to English.
And it's actually kind of hard.
The same, the same problem again.
It's...
I will just read them.
Not to...
I will try to...
Yes.
Yeah, I will try to slow down and answer
it in a more slower way.
So I get a time to think about how can I
pronounce them.
All right.
On my last position, I worked in a team
that developed a European system in the
oil and gas industry.
There was a unified front-end team that
worked on several independent projects
simultaneously.
And it required quite heavy communication
with the rest of the departments.
For example, we got two back-end teams,
the team of analysis, the product
managers, et cetera.
And on the different stages of feature
delivery, it required to...
It required to coordinate across different
teams.
It wasn't always convenient, but
thankfully for that specific approach,
I got some important communication skills
and understanding in general how big
companies and how big teams are structured
and working internally.
In terms of tasks, especially for the last
half of the year in that position,
I was responsible for...
I was responsible for delivering a feature
that will visualize and render some data
in charts.
In charts?
Yeah, just in charts.
All right.
In charts.
Where was I?
Yeah.
And how we translate it in a short,
centralized...
What?
Flexible configuration model was created
for us?
All right, yeah.
It's completely missed the point.
Okay, okay.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Yeah, let's just get through for the rest
of the text.
Okay, okay, okay.
Shortly, it came from a chaotic,
unshaped theme to a centralized,
flexible module that allowed us,
instead of fixing instead of fixing...
Oh!
Andrew from the past used so many
difficult words, but Andrew from the
future don't really know them in English.
All right.
Created some...
Spread across here.
On adding new features instead of fixing
endless.
This word I was looking for, endless.
So, instead of fixing an endless list of
random bags, the team were able to extend
this feature and deliver better
representation that met the customers'
requirements.
At my current position, the team were
working with a CRM for a large company in
the healthcare industry.
The team is...
Hold on.
What I just wrote?
Ah, okay, okay.
The team that was directly involved in the
development process is relatively small,
but we got a lot of responsibility on our
shoulders.
I joined the team right at the beginning
and I got the task to create a system that
will allow to be developed and maintained
across next several years with only one or
two developers.
Thanks for that.
Thanks for a few important decisions.
I can proudly say that for the last few
years of development, all the milestones
were...
Hold on.
I don't know how to construct it
correctly.
Thanks to a number of decisions that were
made and I say this with a bit of pride,
all the deadlines were met over these...
Oh, right.
It used met and deadlines instead of
milestones.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
And thankfully of that important decision
decisions that were made, I can proudly
say that all the deadlines were met during
these last two years without even carrying
the functionality.
The last development product is almost
finished and because of that I'm currently
actively looking for a new position where
I can not just grow as a professional but
also enjoy the society and my profession
in general.
All right, I'm finished.
Thanks, John, for bearing with me across
all the way.
It was much harder actually than I thought
it will be.
At the moment I wrote it I just wrote it
today.
I wrote it today a few hours before the
lesson.
Yeah, as I mentioned before, our team is
almost finished the development process of
the current product and as far as I am
aware of our strategic planning,
the team will be the team will be wait a
second, I'm looking for a word
seems like disbanded, yeah, thanks.
The team will be disbanded and because of
that I'm actively as I mentioned before,
I'm actively looking for my new position
and that's the whole answer actually.
I'm just trying to think how to better say
this thing because you know the direction
itself is kind of putting me in a weak
position so I'm providing the information
that I'm kind of don't have a choice and
I'm tied to always deadlines .
It's not the best way of representation
and providing the information why are you
looking for a new job, I think.
I'm smiling right now it's, you know,
you're always rising at the plank of the
way I can answer these questions
It's a compliment
.
All right before we move forward let me at
least try to create the same answer just
in a little bit of different way Yes since
I already mentioned the delivery and
process of our product is almost finished
and since our team will be probably
disbanded after that I'm looking for a new
position and I always wanted to work in a
multi multinational thank you
multinational international I always
wanted to work in an international team
and this time I want to once again rise up
my plank and join a community where there
will be there will be people ok one moment
how can I express it where will be people
that get more experienced than me I'm just
looking for a better way of saying this
where people that are more experienced
than me and I can be a better professional
or learn something new from them
yeah this is a really common task common
situation when we have to deliver a
feature and it requires attention from
both the back end and front end teams and
in order to cover all the all the main I
don't know all the main things we have to
communicate well with each other the
general way is to be aware of what is
going on on the other side if we no no no
as a front end as a senior front end
engineer it's one of the best one of the
best approaches I'm using on is to
is use the documentation the back end team
is providing and trying to align all of
front end decisions with the direction
with the direction they choose so we will
not conflict in a technical way there is
also there is also situations where you
can where you can get some conflict
situations I don't know how to express it
in a better professional way but we will
get a hint later there is also situations
when you can get a conflict in some way
and the best way the best way to fix it is
to avoid it but if you cannot if you
already cannot do this it's better to
align a meeting and prepare the prepare
some document that will cover that will
cover that will cover it from different
points of view
I got it it actually it's funny every time
because that's the thing we actually doing
currently at my work all right
let me just try it once again I will try
to cover it from a little bit of different
angle one of the best way
during communication with a different team
especially with a backend team it is the
common situation is where we get a
conflict with some point and the best way
to resolve this conflict is to avoid it
and one of the main techniques I am I am
using as a lead of the frontend team as
well as the lead of the backend team on
the other side is to plan the tasks
carefully before deciding to implement
them we use task managers like Jira and
once per week on a specific meeting we are
aligning our plans together and trying to
prevent as many pitfalls as we can and
yeah that's the main technique it works
really well yeah
thank you
all right this question outside of our
mock interview this kind of tricky
question because I didn't have really you
know the experience of fixing some really
critical bugs because I simply didn't have
such one and I think actually it's a
really good opportunity for us to answer
it in a different way because honestly
it's a really good parameter during an
interview and for example this way I will
provide the answer something like during
my career I didn't have I didn't have an
experience of serious serious bugs which
in the production so it means that I don't
have an experience fixing them of course I
had some situations where some minor or
hold on medium level thank you you already
know what I'm trying to say of course I
had some situations where minor or medium
level bugs reached the production and the
fix was kind of trivial it was just a
minor mistake mistake by some of the it
was just a minor mistake by one of the
developers
and yeah that's it the main point is that
I don't have an experience in this area
and my question is how can I cover this
kind of situation
okay I really like the way you answered
John and this is almost exactly how it
would look like with a good structure let
me paraphrase this one just once so in the
scenarios when the bug heating up the
production the first important thing you
have to do is to analyze and categorize
this bug is it minor or mid level so you
can spend some reasonable time fixing it
or is it critical and you have to roll
back the release fortunately for me I
didn't have an experience of doing this
because all the bugs I have all the bugs
that we get in the production we
categorize as a medium or trivial and all
the fixes were delivered strictly in the
same day after a few hours which is
probably telling us that the frontend team
doing the job quite well and yeah
thank you
yeah this is it we already ran out of time
of the lesson have you extra time or not
fortunately that's great thank you John
on my current position this is this is a
horrible way to start an answer on my
current position I had a situation when we
one second I have to check
we were forced that's fine we will fix it
later I've been lucky enough in my current
position to onboard a new developer in our
product because once we were forced to
hire hire what?
hire a new employee
we were forced to hire a new team member
in the frontend team one of the main
challenges no no no a different way during
my career it was the first time I was get
a task to onboard a new member and I faced
many challenges for example how should you
provide the information about the code
base what should you tell the person about
what the product is the way you structure
all these parallel lines together so the
person will spend as less time as possible
and will catch up the development process
so he will be able to deliver features
simultaneously the techniques I used we
didn't have a documentation of the product
at the moment because this initiative was
kind of chaotic and I wasn't prepared for
this the technique I used is to I get a
quick overview of the code base and the
project itself I cover all of the main
architectural and strategic decisions
across the front end code base so the
person will just notice about all the
major stuff and how it works internally is
not really necessary at this point
moreover we were at that moment of
onboarding both of us was on hard
communication with each other I don't know
how to express it in a better way anyway
so at any time if he would get an answer
if a person would have a question we can
align a short not even meeting,
just a short call so I could express how
the things are working or why this crutch
exists and these techniques allowed me to
onboard this person just in three days
with a code base that one and a half year
of age alright alright and yeah I have to
work with how can I end the answers
because it's not a really good way to just
end everything yeah
our first attempt yeah our first attempt
was kind of awkward the really first
attempt a few months ago this one is still
alright yeah thanks John
alright yeah I suggest the same thing we
can even leave the agenda as it is and
just cover the rest of the question
usually there is a lot of things still
I actually love seeing the progress
actually as you were telling all across
the way of our classes one of the biggest
players is slowing down and slowing down
no rushing it's really changing the way
yes
I will also analyze the script and we'll
see what it comes out from it thanks once
again John for the preparation and yeah
have a nice weekend as well John bye bye